that's the time I'm like you know these
literal I'm usually like very chill
about it I'm like it's subjective I get
it I get some reason this one just
really I'd I just don't understand how
this was composed exactly rewatchable
yes but there's no through line to any
of them yeah see exactly why they were
chosen this 2016 list is really this is
what this video is done it's made me
it's made me it's made me a comment box
we gotta become I become what you see in
the common boxes they reject nation it's
Greg alder and I'm John we are going to
watch top 10 most rewatchable movies a
video of that came out in 2016 from
watchmojo.com this comes from patron
request Andrew Hayes one of our reward
tiers is whatever video you request we
must definitely cover on the youtubes on
our patreon we do TV show reactions for
many a shows Plus weekly Q&A is here's
what I got to tell you guys Andrew Hayes
is an ultimate movie review channel he
actually came on this channel this month
when he was visiting loss of the Angelus
what else I can tell you is this this
video is from 2016 you can bet that
Justice League won't be on this list
[Music]
this videos
[Music]
welcome to watchmojo.com and today we're
counting down our picks for the top 10
rewatchable movies for this list we're
picking those classic films that you can
watch a thousand times because they
never get it just set themselves up for
lists videos that give people get a lot
of [ __ ] you know it's gonna save
yourself some of those videos guys see
you like why you need someone put this
on their list Robin Williams manages to
make us laugh and cry timeless classic
when you stop laughing after a while
movie fanatics love mrs. Doubtfire for
its message about fatherly dedication
and how far a parent would go to spend
time with his children
once the father of your children is out
of the picture the only solution is
total and lifelong celibacy maybe a
little extreme at times it's still to
watch alone or on any now what are you
looking at moments like the makeover or
the table hopping climax heartwarming
scenes that show the character's
progression mrs. Doubtfire is a flick
that anyone can enjoy whether it's the
first time you watch it or the 50th oh
that's right number 9 The Royal
Tenenbaums listen I think we're just
gonna have to be secretly and not with
each other and interesting Leslie yeah
of all the dry Wes Anderson classics
this one takes the cake
royal Tenenbaum bought the house on
Archer Avenue in the winter of his 35th
year with its quirky sets sharp humor
and Alec Baldwin's narrating the only
thing that could make this film even
more rewatchable is if you sat down to
watch it with crackers and root beer to
share a sleeping bag and survived on
crackers and boot beer it's fresh
formula and its style of the comedy
resonates with the audience making it
one of those unforgettable films that
you can always come back to exploring
the themes of family loyalty and playful
the trail The Royal Tenenbaums is a
quirky classic that you and your hipster
friends can switch on at parties I'm
thinking a song I just think you kind of
a son of a [ __ ] I really appreciate the
cabin in the woods ask any horror movie
fanatic well he or she keeps a
conference up in all likelihood it's
this one we met him he was nice with an
old other patron Jason Louis Hemsworth
and Richard Jenkins this film delivers
without being something it's not
when you're stuck in some perverted
alien-human killing game it's not gonna
be Oscar material but that's just what
makes this film even more rewatchable
third the action never stops the dark
humor reigned supreme and the laughter
filled the air in the eyes of the
audience every time you watch this
horror satire you'll probably pick up a
reference or a joke that you missed the
first time ever seven worst gum still
haven't seen it and I know it's about to
finally ruin this movie for me after 70
years he or she has seen this movie more
than once like a box of chocolates never
know what you're gonna get yeah it's
like a box of chocolates delivering
something special without being too
obvious as to what you're gonna get with
a likable protagonist and a commanding
narrative Forrest Gump never gets old so
I got a call from them saying we don't
have to worry about money no more and I
said
that's good one less than fits to the
title character's ignorance about his
impact on history it also provides
subtle humor on top of that not only is
historical
awesome features its fair share of
romance action and even social learning
theory to moviegoers standing in the
movie looks like Gump's love for Jenny
his bravery and his optimistic view on
life never escaped the audience and we
can't get enough of this heartwarming
tale Danny hey it wasn't for me
protection of your subconscious we may
not be living in the matrix but how can
we know if life is not all a dream
within a dream you have a snapshot here
you better have the matrix I say that
much we bring the subject into that
dream and they fill it with their
subconscious
thanks to this classic we asked that
question every day this list should be
here
where are you right now
with more action than a Michael Bay film
and more twists than an M night
Shyamalan joint who could have anything
bad to say about the cinematic
more action than a Michael Baisden
[Music]
wouldn't want to watch it just one more
time if not only to understand it a
little better I did watch this in the
bathroom and I was like it was better
the first number 5 me girls
[Music]
I bet annihilation my parents met this
Tina Fey masterpiece chronicles the
anxiety the struggle she wrote it set of
an awkward new girl enter a Midwestern
public high school
I know it's Tina Fey stop talk to me
again and I'll kick your ass
oh yeah did we mention she was home
schooled in Africa you've actually never
been to a middle school that's right so
if you thought your high school
experience was stressful Lindsay Lohan's
in this film is 10 times worse
[Music]
grunts it laughs relatable teenage
obstacles and perceived antagonistic
adult characters this movie is
rewatchable for everyone who's gone to
high school and can now laugh about it
Russian question stop trying to make
fetch happen it's not going to happen
never for a princess block yeah I
definitely said what's this right yeah
[Music]
you want to watch this one again more
Erie Watchers I realize how connected
everything I always have I know now I
always will if you tell me I must marry
you in ten days
please believe I would be dead by
morning who wouldn't want to see the
Dread Pirate Roberts face off one more
time you also discover how you also
discover how bland the princess actually
is it no one of consequence with lovable
characters like Andre the Giant's Fezzik
and an unforgettable grandpa grandson
Deadpool to savage 50:13 cutscene coming
our way beyond the shelf
that's gonna be on that day she was
amazed to discover them when he was
saying as you wish what he meant was
number three The Lion King yeah the
broom better be on here I mean there's
probably some people's most beautiful
I can't wait for John forever to make
this better classic cartoon depicts the
intricate and complex relationships of a
Lion King while portraying the harsh
environment of the African desert and
Savannah this'll all be mine everything
everything light touch but not
everyone's gonna listen as well as for
the heat beams packaged within the
animated child-centric stories huh Cunha
Matata there's so much admiration for
this movie in the film community we
could go on for days you think the
classic circle of life scene speaks for
itself
sure
[Music]
Hey number two Pulp Fiction
quarter pounder with cheese it's still
mr. bisector they don't go on the cooler
in the boutique when we say rewatchable
you'd better not say what messages with
mind-blowing performances by Hollywood
greats like samuel l jackson John
Travolta and uma Thurman this Quentin
Tarantino classic is one you'll be
pulling off the shelf forever says dead
baby with a blend of black comedy dark
action and plenty of pop-culture
references the audience is left stunned
as Tarantino delivers his cultural blend
of gangster wit I want to help you but I
don't wanna lose my wife doing it all
right this classics entertaining stories
and nonlinear narrative keep it fresh
with every viewing and let's not forget
if we watch it just one more time we may
be able to guess exactly what's in that
6 6 6 below before we unveil our number
one pick here are some fundamental
tensions matrices find the fun snap the
game
[Music]
how many people have that's right we'll
watch this movie over and over again
until we have no lives
this is subjective no one does dry humor
and intelligent comedic wit like the
classic Monty Python troupe and this
film delivers like no other comedy
[Music]
people groveling British humour plus a
medieval setting equals one satisfied
audience with an endless list of
quotable lines a memorable cast of
hilarious characters and a killer rabbit
but this is one side-splitting film
is she a witch we may just have to watch
this classic one more time to find out
no no for more enduring top 10s
published every day be sure to subscribe
to watchmojo.com subscribe i only
haven't seen one out of them out of the
10 movies here and you've never watched
any of them but i gotta tell ya this is
a problematic approach to the list I
guess cuz I feel like rewatch ability is
so subjective I mean you got a life you
gotta lay out the rules here he is when
I hear rewatchable does this mean you
get more from it every time you watch it
we're really easy to throw on and have
fun and join Monty Python III don't Oh
Dan are you for being on the list but
most comedies in general I would have a
hard time arguing for it to be on the
voice there was one summer whatever
anchorman came out and on DVD without a
doubt no movie I watched as much as
anchorman that summer I was watching it
at least once a week but I eventually
got to a point where I was like I know
all these jokes I am sick of this movie
60% of the time it works every time that
doesn't make sense even when I watch it
now like I know all these jokes I'm no
longer laughing the fun has left the
department is Doubtfire really really I
feel like as it ages more people
criticize it for kind of its more
twisted elements that was a lot of Chris
Columbus it's so subjective of what
relate of watchable is I just can't
believe you would put inception on here
but not the matrix I'm sorry whoever you
are that made that list but everything
they're saying about inception that
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for the
matrix and the matrix is like a million
times deeper and when you rewatch the
matrix you always learned
something more about the matrix
something about its plot its world you
learn more and they're saying like more
action and stuff and like the matrix has
more action than everything there is a
divine interception the matrix does all
that but better in my opinion
I get why it was on I don't know I mean
I feel like the matrix definitely has
the same rewatch ability factor and yeah
they both have this sort of like can you
understand it gimmick inception that was
the main flavor was people going I gotta
go back and re-watch it to see if I
understand it where's the matrix has
like a bunch of other stuff no one
understood the matrix yeah I know but
you know what the tag but the gimmick
dude yet what is the man's but I feel
like people got more into the game and
the gimmick when it came to inception
than they did with the matrix
I mean association with the matrix isn't
people being like I gotta watch this
fire again to see if I can figure out if
the top falls down there were websites
dedicated to like the matrix has more to
rest on than that gimmick whereas I feel
like that gimmick may have taken center
stage with inception because it's not as
deep of a movie as the matrix I don't
Inception most people still follow it
yeah I've watched it twice and I was
like okay I'm over this the matrix
people were like oh that like people
would geek out about so many different
things
yeah the may of the inception of the
geek out moment was did you figure it
out figure what out what's going on in
the movie yeah I don't know I don't
understand what it was how what's
happening in that movie to not get I
don't know but everybody seemed to think
it was impossible to understand guess I
wasn't around for that part of the
discussion of when inception was that
Princess Bride I'd agree with any time
people like looks like the best film the
show kids what's like the best room
actors it belongs to so many categories
of what is the best this what is the
best this people constantly list
Princess Bride so Princess Bride I would
totally agree with being on this list
other than the fact that I'm like the
princess is kind of a blank character
the more you read watch it the more you
realize that she's the most
uninteresting element
of the movie the title character other
than that I'm like its heart is
constantly just like always present in
you well it's very quotable and I feel
like quotable movies are there's some
kind of crossover in that Venn diagram
of like a very quotable movies probably
a movie you can throw on a lot because
like Mean Girls has that Pulp Fiction
has that you know what else has that the
matrix the matrix has unfortunately no
one can be told what the matrix is you
have to see it for yourself
cabin in the woods I feel like is a fun
one to re-watch because that movie has a
twist
well the rewatch ability factor if the
if the movie has a twist it's fun to
keep rewatching a see the clues the
clues that led to the twist that almost
that we did I didn't see coming I don't
know if cabin the woods actually has
that factor cuz I've only seen it once
when I watch it I was like what the
[ __ ] going on a lot of Easter eggs I
don't know if it has like a bunch of
twists and clues I don't know like the
weird meta fantasy of it is always
present to the audience and so I don't
find that movie as confusing but I think
there are a lot of things to pick up
that you might miss on an initial
viewing references especially you see
the thing about like something like
Forrest Gump some of these films I feel
like oh let me take for Scott I feel
like some of these are just classics
being a classic is like yes it stands
the test of time and you can watch it
repeatedly I've never been like I'm just
gonna spend a week with Forrest Gump on
you know it's not comfort I feel like
rewatchable stuff is also I associate
rewatch ability with comfort food in a
way like Zoolander is really rewash of a
movie for me
I wouldn't put on Forrest Gump just to
chill with that in the Royal Tenenbaums
like I get it especially Royal
Tenenbaums like you know film school
friends like probably watch that movie
of the motion Wes Anderson movies I
think Mean Girls even though I said a
whole spiel about comedy films
I think Mean Girls especially for a
female demographic of what I've noticed
that this film definitely is a highly
really watchable movie it's just the
frustrating thing about some of these
lists
that WatchMojo puts together is when you
see the title you're like there's just
no way you can possibly nail this list
yeah and they don't ever really set it
up for this is just my opinion I guess
why they can get backlash they set it up
as not a subjective thing you know they
set it up as you we did the math we
crunch the numbers and here's what it is
the computer know this kind of list
works though and I think that's why they
I feel like no matter what you're
setting yourself up for backlash of
course but uh but if you don't preface
it with anything this is just our
opinions what are yours
you know then you see yourself up for it
oh my god I can't think of way more
movies that are way more rewatchable I
feel like this yeah is the most it's
funny when they got two honorable
mentions I feel like that was the
tightest cluster of like non-debatable
's because like yeah those are all
rewatchable yeah and I honestly I don't
know I mean Monty Python at number one I
feel like that's a worthy choice I don't
feel like there's ever gonna be a number
one pick that's people everyone's gonna
be like that's the most watchable movie
ever Holy Grail is a decent choice for
them well I feel like you gotta also you
know really define the rules on what you
mean by rewatchable because I'm like
it's so broad yeah it's just like Back
to the Future to me is such a real
watchable movie there are people who are
like every Christmas I put on die hard
I feel like is so subjective like yeah
some of these lists yeah you can kind of
approach a good baseline this I'm like
there's so many movies and everyone's
taste is mad like for me I associate
easily rewatchable movies with stuff
that's generally light and fun but
somebody else might think of a war movie
as a movie they want to write alright
you've got all of cinema here like what
are we doing most of these movies you
don't see as people's like lists for
best movies of all like if you see a
list of 10 best movies of all time you
can probably count on a few being in
that list you know probably gonna throw
the Godfather there you know
they're probably gonna throw Citizen
Kane or Casablanca yeah like Empire
Strikes Back those four films are a
general
unlike people's best of list what did
that mean that there are probably some
of the most rewatchable movies of all
time as well at least one of those you
know Empire Strikes Back
out of those four that we listed I'm
like Empire's probably the most watch in
my opinion I'd watch I've seen Godfather
probably more than I've seen Empire cuz
I'm fancy Empire Strikes Back like Star
Wars movie on this list look if I had a
rewatchable list passion to Christ yeah
scary movie for Serbian Film I'm more
like an honorable mention and then I
would also probably throw in the the
Snyder yeah alright guys well what's
your list of rewatchable movies you can
subscribe to watchmojo.com petrie our TV
show reactions q and A's would love to
have you and me and everyone around here
become a patron of Jax a day